Hallo Stefan.
Genau obwohl ich ja so früh eigentlich noch nicht rauche eher am Abend.
Genau. Wir machen ja kleinen TSA bevor wir in den Salon reingehen.
Es sind ja zwei Themen eingefallen die vielleicht es noch keine Literatur sagen wir mal so Zum einen.
Für mich ist das Wichtigste das will ich jetzt vorwegnehmen dass du dich ja festlich angezogen hast weil wir über Lagerfeld sprechen.
Stefan Schulz im Anzug das ist ja was ganz Besonderes.
Gibt es gleich ein Foto Beweis Ich habe Quatsch angezogen.
Und ich habe einen Lagerfeld Hemd extra angezogen.
Ja das sieht spektakulär aus den Kragen manchmal ein Kino den Kragen noch einmal sehen wenn ich an Lagerfeld selbst denke denke ich an diesen Haifisch.
Und das scheint doch ein bisschen subtiler zu sein etwas was er dir da auf.
Genau das. Bei ihm sind es ja ein sind es ja solche einstellbaren Kragen und das ist nochmal ein Unterschied hier ist es halt einfacher ein Hemd und da ist wie es ist.
Das gehört zum Design. Es sieht so aus als würde so eine Schleife lose darum baumeln aber es ist alles fest auf dem Hemd genäht. Ja ja da ist nichts sondern es sieht so aus als hätte man auch noch eine Schleife umgebunden.
Aber es ist einfach auf das Hemd fest genäht und das sind solche schönen Details die Lagerfeld dann auch in seiner eigenen Kollektion die er eigentlich immer ein bisschen vernachlässigt hat dann untergebracht hat.
Und Ja aber das ist alles sehr bezahlbar muss man jetzt dazu sagen.
Digg.
Das ist ganz normal wie man für ein Hemd zahlt wenn man jetzt eine der üblichen Marken nimmt und irgendwie ein Hemd für die Arbeit oder was braucht.
Das kann nicht flattern was du da um den Hals hast das ist so drauf weil es sieht flatternd aus das ist interessant.
Nein nein das kann nicht flattern.
Es geht als sehr gut. Karl Lagerfeld ist ein Profi zwingen wir ihn gleich als Erstes aber wie gesagt es gab es seit wir den letzten Salar aufgenommen haben und es ist nur vier Tage her Bewegung in der Welt hast du die Debatte geguckt zwischen Trump und beiden.
Ich muss gestehen nur in Auszügen weil ich es kaum ertragen habe. Und ich habe auch nicht vor das jetzt noch komplett nachzuholen muss ich gestehen.
Du hast ja ganz angetan musstest es tun für den Fernseh Podcast.
Du hast auch wenig verpasst.
Ach was heißen musste ich wollte denn so wie wir auch im Salon gleich über Bob Woodward großes zweites Buch zur Trump Präsidentschaft schreiben interessiert mich schon wie man das jetzt beerdigt wie man diese Sache einfach beerdigt. Insgesamt.
Ich hätte mich sehr gefreut wenn nicht nur Trump aus dem Rahmen gefallen wäre sondern auch mal Chris Valles um zum Beispiel Fragen zu stellen Wie hat es Spaß gemacht Trump. Was hat es gebracht.
So auf der Ebene diese persönliche Ebene wurde nicht gefunden als nächstes kommt eine Town Hall da muss sich Trump den Fragen von Bürgern stellen die er auch als Wähler erkennt.
Da wird er nicht so auftreten wie gegen Wales wo alle Wähler im Hintergrund abgedunkelt oder gar nicht anwesend waren.
Da bin ich nochmal gespannt darauf wie er sich da gibt es ist dann am 15..
Aber ich gucke das jetzt wirklich nur noch unter diesen pietistischen gründen. Wie kommt man aus der Nummer wieder raus.
Denn wir haben auch gesehen jetzt im Nachgang der ersten Debatte. Viele haben immer noch Angst vor Trump aber die Gewinner Frage konnte man jetzt klären anhand von Umfragen Fokus Gruppen Auswertung.
Qualitativ sind und auch wer bekommt denn das Geld hinterher geschmissen nach so einer Debatte.
Und Trump bleibt dabei keine nennenswerten Einnahmen.
Aber das gab es dann drei Millionen am Tag aber bei beiden stellt einen Rekord nach dem anderen auf gerade einmal täglich Zuwächse die üblicherweise nicht einmal monatlich erreicht werden von Kandidaten die sich da bewerfen.
Das ist wirklich grandios wie sich das muss man leider sagen. Wall Street Hollywood Silicon Valley da einkauft in diese künftige Präsidentschaft.
Genau das wird dann auch wieder furchtbar werden wahrscheinlich.
Und nun hat Trump Coruna.
Ja deswegen ist ja erst einmal fraglich ob am 15. Mai dann die Debatte stattfindet ist ja nicht mehr der Jüngste und wir wissen ja dass da Coruna doch erheblich,
erheblich dazu beitragen kann dass man nicht dann 14 Tage später eine tolle Debatte abliefern kann.
Wir wissen von Trump dass er schauspielert immer hat heute Morgen geschrieben.
Ich habe jetzt den Prozess begonnen und wenn er wenn wir ihn glauben was er damit meint dann hieße das ja einfach nur dass jetzt zwei Wochen aus und dann ist gut.
Das hieße er schafft die Debatte und so weiter. Aber Trump ist 74 und übergewichtig und es sind nunmal die beiden Zwicker für Risikogruppen Bewertung.
In der Hinsicht ist das jetzt nochmal eine neue Dynamik.
Ich fand die Nachricht wurde heute Morgen sehr locker aufgenommen. Man hat seine Witze über Trump gleich unterlassen um dann sofort zu sagen keine Witze darüber.
Man hat sozusagen den einschritt übersprungen den man bei Boston auch noch gemacht hat beispielsweise mit Tweets wie man etwas Positives zu erfahren. Er hat Coruna solche Tweets gab es heute Morgen nicht in Sicht. Mal gucken wie das ausgeht.
Aber gut wir gehen jetzt also bei mir nicht so.
Ich habe doch ein paar dieser Art gelesen aber das sind dann vielleicht doch einfach die die noch in der Schublade lagen von Euro die man jetzt nochmal neu aufbereitet.
Ich hab nur ein lustiges gelesen wo es eingefangen wurde da hieß es dann blabla Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht feixen uns drüber lustig machen.
Das kann jedem passieren. Donald Trump,
hat aber keine Witze über Namen. Wir gehen jetzt in den Salon lesen Karl Lagerfeld lesen lesen.
David Graeber Gott habe ihn selig sein Bullshit Buch hat sich noch als sehr ergiebig erwiesen.
Ich habe es wirklich mit Freude nochmal gelesen. Wirklich gut.
In der Tat.
Und ein bisschen Plastik ein bisschen China und für alle die den Salon nicht gebucht haben bekommt jetzt gleich irgendein Podcast für alle dieser Mitglieder sind beginnt direkt nach diesem denn das lässt sich Timon.
Ich hoffe ich verspreche jetzt nicht zu viel aber eine Minute später nach diesem hier ist das veröffentlicht.
Also gehen jetzt die Salan Türen auf.